so it's a tough question if you can't
design the world what would you ideally
and if this was a genie coming out of a
bottle and saying emulation in the world
I would eliminate the property so many
else of this world today are because of
profits and poverty and it would start
with enabling each person to make their
own livelihood to take themselves
forward and have a sense of empowerment
that they can control their destiny
however it's very difficult to eliminate
poverty and programs is that one of
those wishes that will never come true
so the next step would be to truly make
education for all and in addition to
making education reform oh make sure
that if you have mobility and if you do
work hard and strive hard then you can
achieve what you want and that would be
meritocracy and so this will end on
eliminating corruption and holding
accountable both officials and school
teachers and parents do not give
children the accessibility to education
but also a fair chance at life if they
prove themselves worthy and willing to
present the festivities of the